[Music]
especially if you're horny yes you know
I refrain from using that joke it's like
somebody had to get it out it's like
taking the last dessert it's like who
would be selfish enough to do it
good morning Tamra it's like when we
shot with yeah well good morning 3:00
a.m. or whatever it's like now you get
to have a bird mark any of it obviously
no the funniest thing was when I went to
breakfast afterwards and we went to
juicy O's which is Gracie Rufio at
Jersey yes yeah the he said they're like
in full outfit yes are you okay with
going in there you know because we said
we can just get which McCord
take out it's like not gonna do it it
was until like halfway through the
conversation because he was so
jet-lagged had to get up so early and
don't what you do is that way they it's
just like you know it's just so nice
being here with you guys and talking I
have stuff on my face dog right like
inside and we hit him but he's in the
row
yeah the coffee finally started getting
to his brain they allow us to take him
out of the whole wonder if California is
a home I think those restaurants are
starting to recognize us cuz we're
always going in there with like well
maybe I think I've went in there with
like white hair once no you mean like oh
I say mailing from be earnest and don't
they see it's like oh it's
yeah it's no when you had white skin at
one time oh man there's a guy walking by
and we're like they will he get a police
react please react to the guy deserved
[Music]
well now there was someone does Malcolm
said all I wanted to do was to get into
the Woodridge yeah I said I said I want
to go into your library yeah that was
the shining Roo you because I mean we're
just standing in the middle of a forest
and I've got makeup on my face and Jim's
just like no putting it on and the guy
walks by he just looks and keeps going
that was the line there's a joke and if
they have to look ridiculous we already
have an outfit for you because it was
the pencil head
oh just gonna have that but now say but
whatever it's like I
I don't know this territory I just know
there's like it has to sound funny when
she's blocking no I know but it's like
the material has to look like that
material I have no idea that materials
like really tight or movable or whatever
so luckily he found an outfit that it
looks like to be okay
you know it's like it's not gonna like
[Music]
it's really shiny yes have to look loud
yeah just have like a cat
like a cat costume like a slutty cat
costume oh there's just like tight black
and I was like am I playing a cat the
cat I can't win no sense of humor so
yeah I can't well I'll say it both of
you you know just sir have you both seen
in the movies yeah at least hey have you
seen matrix Tamara
[Music]
we can get a clip the woman in the movie
I need just like is even more dead
straight face thank you
whoa very much like this I even like
women when she's dying spoiler even when
like in the third film she's like really
he's blind when she dies to something
like that
remember I just yeah varies by whole
thing yeah you're like C's in matrix
code or something right i guy won't give
him you have to see if you movies or at
least one of them so you got a few but
no this will be fun cuz I'm like I've
never found anyone else that dislike the
matrix so I might be like the first it's
like I know they're out there that's I
mean the point of this is that the ailes
again I know this I know your album
people who don't like the beach the
revolution has begun we will show the
world and blah blah blah okay everyone I
talked to even people that like aren't
obsessed with they like super obsessed
but they're like just you didn't like
the matrix I just I never met one punch
me like wow do you really don't like you
do these are turning in their grave yeah
well they will after they hear someone
doesn't like the matrix well that nobody
likes the sequel's that so either they
everybody it's a in the review I had
that's like you mean the sequence
I thought it was alright okay
whatever kind of doll that has goals
whatever yeah oh yeah I mean reality no
science bitches torian's ever tapped on
that like ever
yeah that is a good point everyone has a
narrow vision isn't that the name of the
guy who's running the night club Oh what
the French guy yeah again nobody
remembers in this evening always yet
another makeup that's gonna take a lot
of time it's gonna look great
it's only gonna be on screen for like a
couple seconds yeah terrible no you know
that's like the one that's like you know
oh my god you were that do bar that like
I liked it but I can't think of the
camera for if you want to be oh sure
even though you played the devil is the
first time you're gonna have horns oh
yeah I remember one time you were saying
that I should have liked horns coming
through yeah we tried it on the head to
see if it will look when we're trying to
get the design of the character and
never it was a little too much like just
the head alone you had such a presence
like it seemed to work the recording is
flashing as I'm a it should turn it off
and turn off like that
oh no it's recording just fine okay I
just wasn't and what what's the focus
again right in the edge right on the
edge yeah there we go much more focused
II Yugi
Lucio's that's what they're told Lucci
horns that's what the code and another
very different oh well this the company
makes uh mister they're called Universal
horns by Wu chi-wai will change
sounds very yes people come on here you
play with your Wu Chi there oh we
stopped making private part jokes what
is wrong with you what we everyone think
of it it's like hi how you doing hi I'll
tell you what's hi was that yeah why me
do although that's no you're gonna be
looking forward though so it should be
like that yeah even though this does
kind of look cool but it's like they
should be like that yeah yeah because
you're gonna be looking like right the
computer screen the camera is the
unicorn Pony you are going to look I
actually play into where we would do the
Care Bear stuff first and then watch
before the major cuz I'm like there's no
way we're going to watch I mean Greg
we've come in there with more ridiculous
like I said during the Bosco she advice
what and that's your up it was falling
apart wasn't in the Bosco I like the we
had to tape it up like mad it was
yeah we're grab a similar experience
like that today this ensemble over
Tamara has on today was brought to you
by star to say yeah that's like my
superpower I guess I I think when you're
when you're in film it's like thrift
stores are Cal like your personal friend
yeah I've got a few costumes and props
in there before Jim I know you must but
the nice thing like you can find like
things you can find like all these
various you know just anything yeah well
you can find an a card and it'd be like
ooh like that look good on this person
and just like you look amazing like
somehow you turn into something else by
combining with something else I I can't
see that way I'm always amazed by people
I can one of the best at anything and
look at porn the man come it's a sister
I'm trying not to make any faces yeah
cuz I kept falling off because putting
it on so so that's it let's go ahead and
shoot this fucker yes this is after the
horns are off I say it was a very
Hellboy inspired look and then we said
hell girl and then you said hyper hyper
hell girl
spin-off character that's so hyper hell
yes what yeah I was like yes debt you
always need cushion there that's like
it's like if you were an otter maybe
what's the difference a jacket is like
here oh it goes all the way down to this
toe okay when you put a kid in a coat
for winter you don't say hey you put on
your comfort on your jacket and they go
really like it's the same I don't think
that Thomas Anderson's parents said go
put your jacket on okay the red jackets
come on yes
I taught you the difference between a
code by God I mean it carries in your
jackets think I'm doing burry sculpey
nurse Oh
oh this oh yeah lovely ensemble they
can't smile straight see it take that's
a pair you'll breathing you think that's
air you're breathing no it's gonna be
Suze you said they're lighter Michael
that's gonna work yeah do that is more
fees nitrate does he have like does he
leave it open or know the code
no no no I I think he burns out I wanna
see he bunts it like all the way to the
top yeah yeah like I think maybe in the
sequel he left it open but I'm pretty
sure he had it all buttoned a button you
don't know how button works yeah where's
the app for it
some things we did for that yeah we just
bonded all the way up
getting you ready for cat school yes
God's got school oh no that's my
favorite thing it's like you know we're
here to blend into the matrix it's like
yeah exactly
do the belt to wrap the belt around even
the belt I really do feel like Laurence
Fishburne jokes I knew it well played
that would be hilarious in the middle of
one of battles Morpheus it's just like
wait go time I shoot calls up tank hold
the matrix we're just yeah operator tie
shoe I know how to tie my shoe hold on I
could just eat it so the idea is I'm
sitting here somewhere
keeping the review and then schmuck
comes in oh my god and I go Malcolm is
Tammany help me and originally you come
in from like either side like where did
you guys come from but I'm trying to I
can't think of any area around here like
where they would be for like it's still
talking on the shoulder or do you want
to bend down and then just stand up into
the frame no I like courage like because
I had to come into frame ah
and if they're there it's gonna be so
quick like when I turn they call them
that
then people would register open right
there look the NC is doing work don't
you know why they do that scene if he's
not know the training he's not teaching
new he's convincing me oh he can do it
that's very important don't you
understand this could should I have to
here let me explain again in the
beginning no I think actually you can be
in Choctaw about like right here yeah
but let's turn around like you're facing
and then I say you know I come into
frame
Oh
yeah nobody but turn lights up real good
[Music]
okay so so what what it's going to be so
I see here I come into frame what
Malcolm intended so as I see Malcolm is
that's when you to turn have any help me
and you walk up to either side Malcolm
on this side
Tamara on this side walk up and I'll
have extra light here I'm not going to
have any help me kick this guy's ass and
you say I'd like to quit but I have
taught you everything I know about being
a good leader you want to tell me shit
no but I've made a lot of good speeches
Timoney help me I can't my outfit is so
tight I love it oh my god yeah you can I
think do it once and you know just what
I chant and then yeah yeah but wait why
would that be why would he not be able
to get out I can't my mother won't allow
me to that's funny
okay let's do that let's change the line
let's change it to you know I can't my
mother won't let me take out you know
fully achieve my sword oh I like to add
on to what she has to say no because you
already see the line of like you know I
don't need to I've taught you everything
you go on your way be a leader and stuff
like that and but then it's like you're
trying to help it that wouldn't it one
coincide I think just do the sword thing
I think that's fine oh so it starts off
with your mouth your wardrobe
malfunction and her
okay so I like that better I think
that's funny so okay so yeah so Tammany
Cummings I kicked my leather won't allow
me to fully OSI myself tell me how would
you I can't my leather again my leather
is so my mother won't allow me to move
my gun my leather is so tight along and
then we just look like you know oh it's
okay so pretty much chips it's sort of
like the moves I was doing before where
I come into frame it's mostly kind of
still when they come in and mouthing
starts doing that they just do like a
little bit of tracking on them you know
it been like what he's done serve what
about you would serve the same thing
just a little bit of movement ability
thunder serve strike back and get all
three okay so it's me with them in the
background take them in Malcolm to me to
her and action Oh help me
I can't right let the won't allow me
achieve my sword so yeah like as soon as
he comes up that's we can start to come
in he comes in I can't my little lamb
again she cries sword Germany kicked his
ass
I can't my leathers too tired but let me
move my gun good I put a little bit more
if it's inside my love my love is so
tight big lava bucket my legs just
[Music]
[Applause]
that's Tamra that throw it's way too low
literally throw it over your head
because we'll see it against the white
[Applause]
yeah that's right you throw it back
against the door yes yeah there you go
that's right destroy the studio but
that's okay
we die for our art
I could do one where I put it over
glasses and I'm good to one where it's
like I barely even cover I might just go
like that
there's a crow Samurai yeah yeah
voiced by Samuel Jackson yeah samurai
badass right Tamra coffee there's a cool
outfit wedge' fied
oh dear pretty cool
and we ozzy osbourne no sleep till
Brooklyn here's a question for you
do you ever remember even hearing about
Clutch Cargo
yeah I don't yet without yeah all that I
know what to give it was they animated
at all but they didn't put any mouth in
and then when the voice actors would
voice apart they film the mouth so the
mouth was a real mouth talking like this
in the rest of it you know well how are
you doing cluck Oh for you kids watching
there's a clip of it in Pulp Fiction
yeah walking does the watch yet yeah
budging Klitschko on TV I'm gonna try
something I hear I bet you've never
tried before if there actually is a song
something creative
instant cool this is him badass in a
glass you do it like a secret agent or
something
[Music]
how was really good hmm want me to do
something no no you did oh I did and
that's how slow you did and it was just
like sorry huh
I got to show you that cuz that was just
like pure chance that you did this and
now it looks amazing cuz it's in slow-mo
here hold on that's gotta go in the
behind the scenes whatever scratching
your eye hmm thinking like no now I'm
shooting no okay yeah that's the new
dance
[Music]